So now that net neutrality has been rolled back the FCC is blocking a law enforcement
investigation into suspected comment fraud despite the fact that at least one actual senator was
Impersonated in what is just abundantly clear,
rampant comment fraud and the lead up to the repeal of net neutrality by the FCC. So the backstory on this is that
Supposedly the FCC received just tons and tons of comments
against net neutrality or said a different way the FCC received a ton of comments in favor of
repealing net neutrality
Which never really made sense it didn't even pass the sniff test because we know
That public opinion is overwhelmingly in favor of net neutrality
And you'd have to believe that the small portion of the population opposed to it was so strongly opposed to it that they in
insanely
Disproportionate numbers were the ones writing to the FCC of course the truth is that we've seen data analyses done by mathematicians
language analyses
And it appears that there was a major amount of fraud and fake comments
Supporting the repeal of net neutrality well
That's something we would want to investigate right well not according to the FCC the FCC is
Blocking this investigation you have New York Attorney General Eric Schneiderman who's trying to investigate
But the FCC is not giving them anything
it's not giving them any of what they need to actually figure out what the hell happened here to quote our fearless orange leader a
Schneiderman wrote a letter saying that they're getting no help from the FCC an FCC lawyer wrote back saying yeah
We have no interest in helping law enforcement
Period they imply the entire investigation would be irrelevant anyway
And they're actually trying to use the argument of privacy at least in part to resist helping in this
Investigation they said listen your staff has previously asked us to provide logs of IP
Addresses for some of these comments if we give you IP addresses of public commenters, we would be potentially
exposing their identity
Which would be a privacy concern which is hilarious that all of a sudden now?
The FCC's number-one priority is privacy in the meantime just to put a fine point on just how insane this comment fraud
Situation is Senator Jeff Merkley found out he's a Democrat
he found out that he was impersonated during the FCC comment period and that under his name an
Anti net neutrality comment was submitted, which is just insane because he's a public official with an on-the-record
Position in favor of net neutrality he tweeted yesterday turns out someone impersonated me
during the FCC net neutrality comment period further proof of forged comments in this process we need to get to the bottom of this and
Demand justice for those who sought to be heard check out the comment that was submitted under his name
Which we'll put up on the screen for you here
Under his name the eff a comment was submitted where he supposedly said
the FCC's net neutrality rules were written in the Obama White House by political staff and tech
industry special interests who overruled the FCC's own experts the FCC's own chief economist Tim
Brennan called the rules an economics free zone. They should be repealed
That sure sounds like something Democratic Senator Jeff Merkley would say ha so what's the situation either
This is some kind of troll or this was done in such massive numbers this comment fraud
That murkly's identity was caught up alongside millions of others and used for these fraudulent comments
I don't know how his name in particular became wrapped up in this
But this is the real voter fraud that Republicans have been talking about it's not people voting twice
It's not dead people voting in presidential elections. It's not
Massachusetts boat voters being bused into, New Hampshire
To vote for Hillary Clinton it's millions of fake comments purporting to support net neutrality
The FCC here is functioning as if they're above the law
They shouldn't be above the law and New York Attorney General Eric Schneiderman will hopefully keep the pressure on here
And you can actually get involved here. I've said before what we really need to do is vote them out
That's going to be the real way to
Reinstate net neutrality, and we're taught
We'll talk after in the show about a couple other things that are going on, but you've got to vote them out
But in the interim call your Attorney General in your state
You can just Google who is my attorney general or use the link in the sources for the YouTube clip for this story
Call your Attorney General and demand an investigation into this because I assure you even though it won't get net neutrality reinstated
If you can tie up the FCC with investigations by attorneys general nationwide
It's not going to be good for them
And that's exactly what we should be looking to do the video you just finished watching was made possible by you
Through the membership program, you can sign up for membership at david pakman.com slash membership
We are viewer supported independent media. You can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of your membership